hey guys I'm Abby Shar welcome to Abby's
kitchen so I made it to the other side
and here at motherhood and I've got a
really healthy and happy baby to prove
it so thank you guys all so much for the
warm wishes and as you probably remember
before I gave birth I shared my hospital
bag essentials video and it was a really
favorite one of mine and you know I'm a
type-a girl so I wanted to be as
prepared as humanly possible but like
everything in motherhood things do not
go as planned so today I want to take a
little walk down memory lane and share
with you some of the things that I
definitely never even took out of the
bag and the things that were truly
essential for labor and delivery let's
do this
[Music]
obviously I'm trying to be flexible as
much as a type-a personality can be but
we still want to write things out so
that we have an idea of what we wanted
to do but also so that we can pass this
on to our labor and support team so that
they understand what my wishes are so
funny story totally forgot the birth
plan I thought I did at least and then
like I was scrambling I was like which
pocket isn't anything of my in person
it's my bag which bag is it in I was
trying to pull it up on my phone to
share with everybody I eventually found
it and thankfully all the labor and
delivery staff were super accommodating
in following my wishes and you know as
best as they could so I think that was
definitely a must spring next hair
elastics I know this sounds silly but of
all the things when I asked all my mom
friends what do I make basically really
need at hospital
they all just say you need hair elastics
so the funny thing is is I brought one
hair elastic I mean I brought them all
but I only needed the one that was in my
hair I don't know why a my head I
thought I needed to like bring a super
bag full of hair elastics that's it like
you know in the in the few hours that I
was in the hospital that they were just
gonna keep breaking I guess it's good to
have a backup but at the end of the day
if you came with a hair elastic in your
hair you probably are good to go
just saying I love Candis I love Candis
on a good day and I'm sure when I'm in
labor I need a little quick hit of
energy I'm definitely going forward the
sugar guys bring in candies I ate so
many candies because at some point I got
an epidural and at that point they
weren't really wanting me to eat
anything so all I consumed was candies
hard candies apple juice and like 12
popsicles I cleaned them out at
popsicles I ate all the popsicles in the
ward so if your word has popsicles eat
the popsicles but the downside of all
this was once I had the epidural I
couldn't walk therefore I couldn't brush
my teeth and my mouth felt like like it
was so grainy and
and you know that film that you get on
your teeth on your teeth and the size
your mouth and you've had too much sugar
that's what I was dealing with and it
was driving me crazy so that's the only
downside of eating all those candies
other than the sugar high but you're
gonna definitely need some energy and
candies are kinda licious way to do that
belly bag so I heard about this because
I am kind of like a fitness buff and one
of my like big fears is something called
diastasis recti if you haven't heard of
that it's basically the separation of
your abdominal muscles and it's very
common during pregnancy if not pretty
much inevitable two different degrees
I've tried really hard to avoid any kind
of strenuous core work during my
pregnancy so as to minimize the damage
so here's the funny thing about the
belly band I was like really gung-ho on
using this right from the get-go in the
hospital like right after delivery but
my stomach felt like because I had
something called a retained placenta
which basically meant that my placenta
got stuck in there we didn't just like
flop at it like it does for a lot of
women or was like easily delivered the
doctors had to literally reach their
whole arm up into me and kind of scrape
it out while literally pounding on my
belly too huge
they weren't huge but two adults we're
just punching my stomach trying to get
this uncle sent out so let's just say my
belly was a little bit sore and I did
not really feel like squeezing myself
into like a corset and I didn't really
feel like using it again for like a week
after giving birth so did I need to
bring it to the hospital no I probably
also wouldn't bring it again next time
even if I did not have retained placenta
because you're just sore you just feel
like crap you don't want to be like
trying to squeeze into tight little
clothes the same heating and cooling
packs so I have this little heat pack
that is you plug it in I like this
because then I don't have to go and like
microwave a bag if I may not have access
to a microwave wall little ditto for the
cooling
because you may not have access to a
freezer to kind of keep freezing like a
gel pack or you know an ice pack so
these were things that I actually legit
thought that I was definitely going to
use heating I did not want anything to
do if I was already sweating balls in
there during labor and delivery the
cooling packs probably would have come
in handy had I remembered that I packed
them but what I ended up doing was just
having my husband grab a towel and wet
it in there really cold water and then
just put it on my back and that worked
just as well I mean you're right there
next to a sink you can just kind of keep
running under that cold water and also
on the board a lot of them have ice so
you can also just grab some ice and put
it in a towel as well if you don't want
to have to schlep or buy any of these
kind of cooling packs great idea but
when you're in tons of pain you're
really not thinking about all of these
little tools and tricks that you may be
packed away let's move on to my hubby my
beloved husband okay
so reading materials since a hurt leg is
being so and this one's for me obviously
maybe it's for him I don't know so
here's the thing when you're in labor
you have no patience to be like sitting
down leisurely flipping through the rub
report or cosmopolitan you are working
there's a reason they call it labor and
your birth partner or in my case my
husband he's working too because he's
got to be there to support you
there was no downtime and the downtime
that we did have when I finally got the
epidural was spent sleeping and trying
to get like a little bit of a rest
before the big show a lot more high-tech
option the iPad
Netflix is kifo so ditto with the iPad
phones probably more than enough and
you're gonna be busy and I just think
it's really funny that I was thinking
that after I gave birth I'd have like a
ton of leisurely time to just let it
land around and like watch Downton Abbey
or other Netflix shows or read my
magazines not happening you're spending
that whole time just dealing with a
screaming child and trying to figure out
how to feed it so yeah you're not gonna
have any
times in hospital wait till you get home
there's gonna be plenty of late nights
to enjoy that Netflix show planning to
probably want to use the shower while
I'm in labor
I kind of interested by the idea of like
being in the shower with where other
Explorer previously giving birth I know
they clean um but still it's a weird
thought for me so this is going to kind
of protect my feet from being on the
gross Hospital shower floor so I know it
was in my birth plan to get in the
shower and I even made a big stink at
the beginning of my labor because I
wanted a room with a shower just because
of that but when it got down to it and I
was in so much pain the last thing I
wanted to do was to get into like a hot
steamy shower or really like adding
water at by the time I decided I wanted
an epidural I like had it in my head and
I was like no [ __ ] way a shower is
gonna cut it when I need like full-on
medical intervention here folks so hey
you might feel differently you might be
able to get away with Justin just a
shower or something like that for pain
management but it was not gonna do it
for me perfectly from a puppy and
parsley for me depending on the time I
mentioned before that a lot of hospitals
really eat but the let your husband's
eat that's that I know for sure and my
husband is going to be hungry so I've
got lots of like granola bars and nuts
and other little snacks that he can
enjoy drink later okay so the snack game
is really important here folks
in fact I suggest you have a whole bag
just for snacks and you may not get to
eat them all at once at least but you
might the day afterwards and in the
early save your labor he might as well
yeah my hubby it basically ate every
snack I packed in there between their
granola bars and the chips and the nuts
he was pretty satisfied I think he was
doing okay
plus he went and had full meals at the
cafeteria as well and then the next day
when it comes to actually giving birth
and having that cut a post-birth meal
there we gave birth in the morning so we
were lucky enough that the cafeteria was
open but I did not feel like eating for
like hours after giving birth because a
I just
my gut says and B I hadn't eaten for
like 12 hours before that and see I had
a postpartum hemorrhage so I felt like
however I definitely enjoyed my
croissant with goats cheese and figs a
few hours later so you may not need
those snacks but it wouldn't be bad just
have them just in case you do give birth
in the middle of the night and if you
don't eat them then trust me you're
gonna definitely appreciate the fact
that you have KD and you know like
noodles dried noodles you just throw in
the microwave ready to go at your
disposal because you're not gonna feel
like cooking anything for like weeks
/ months maybe a year after giving birth
you need to bring your own pillow
because I mean you could get away with
these in the hospital pillows but if
you're like me you can't sleep on
anything that is not your comfortable
pillow so you're definitely gonna want
to bring your own pillow case because
the ones in the hospital are so
uncomfortable and crappy and I also
really think that having a colorful
pillowcase is really a good idea as well
however my only caveat here is probably
skip the silk finish on that pillowcase
because one thing that they don't tell
you nobody told me this but after you
give birth you sweat like a pig
definitely right after giving birth but
also for like weeks
/ months plus a year afterwards so with
the silk finish it really really really
exacerbates that so go with some basic
cotton and some kind of great pattern or
color and you're good to go baby
so again I thought I liked the whole kit
here packed with stuff for baby but some
of the things that I absolutely cannot
forget are some diapers because I hear
that sometimes hospitals don't even
provide at me so you want to make sure
that you have newborn diapers ready to
go for the little depth so the diapers
thing is really important honestly I
know our baby and myself as well we're a
big fan of Pampers Swaddlers diapers and
pampers sensitive wipes and you're gonna
need a lot of them because even though
that baby is so small and teeny and tiny
and you cannot believe how much is
coming out of them they are gonna pee
and poo up a storm even in that first
day of life so stock up and I say you
know
they call it a diaper Bay for a reason
you might as well fill it up onesies are
something to wear so I'm packing a few
things because I just don't know how big
or cold to my little one mate so that
was kind of a smart idea because even
though I gave birth in April we happen
to get birth in a really freak snowstorm
/ ice storm it was crazy so having some
warmer clothes was actually really
really important because we had to
transport him outside into a blizzard so
having a few options that are different
sizes was kind of a good call also maybe
a couple blankets because you're gonna
need to put those receiving blankets on
either side of the little baby's head
when he's in the car seat so a few
options but you don't need to go
overboard baby book not like totally
essential but for me it's just something
that we can might be able to play with
after baby's born so it's a cute little
memorabilia thing where we can take some
photos and and put some information
about what time baby was born the name
of course so cute thought I loved it but
like I said before you are so busy after
you give birth there is no time for
busting that thing out and putting all
these cute little details in and writing
a story I mean I am like seven weeks
postpartum and I still haven't even
opened that book because I just want
time for it you know you're scrambling
and that day after you give birth is so
hectic so exhausting you know it is
probably one of the hardest days of your
life so you're not gonna have any energy
left to be filling in a memorabilia book
for me might not be essential for you
guys but I am planning to bank our cord
and
placental tissue so we have a kit here
that has all the instructions and I
basically just handed over to the
doctors may know - Sara means
but I have to make sure that I bring
this to the hospital when I go into
labor so good news everything went as
planned with our cord and placental
banking I remembered the kit and it was
definitely essential for me but might
not be an essential one for you guys
Hospital without it our car seat so
we've already installed the base into
our car that's obviously really
important because otherwise well you
can't really go anywhere with this okay
so the car seat was definitely a must
for us that one is non-negotiable you're
gonna need something to get from the
hospital to home so don't forget it
definitely don't forget that one
so guys thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this little recap I got
so many great comments from you all
about how you didn't use most of things
in your hospital bag either so it's good
to know I'm not the only one who is
always chronically over packing and
over-prepared so if you loved this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below with some other things
that you have found essential or not so
essential in your hospital bag subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]